hey guys what's up I'm Alana and today
we are going to be talking about all the
movies and games and stuff that came out
in August and what I think of those
things first things first is a game that
I actually reviewed by IGN which is
Batman telltale episode 1 so for those
who don't know in telltale games are
episodic very very story driven games
where you basically choose dialogue
options and that affects relationships
but overall the trend seems to be that
the outcomes don't change all that
dramatically so the appeal is actually
in figuring out what's going on with
different characters and getting to know
them I think and tell tales Batman
definitely already has me interested in
a lot of the characters but it did one
thing that I really really really hate
which is tons of exposition so one
example of this is that Batman's parents
are dead we know but for whatever reason
Intel's help Batman episode 1 they tell
you that so many times and in ways that
it doesn't make any sense like this is
old couple at a party and they're like
ah must have sucked your parents to have
died who says that maybe that would be
someone who doesn't know that that man's
parents are dead but this brings it up
like 5 times if you brought it up once
it would be fine
don't repeatedly shove it in my face
because that I think is legitimately bad
storytelling so that's frustrated me
real bad but this is the best looking
telltale game so far I think it's on a
new engine I believe the characters are
really interesting and different to how
they are in the comics which means that
it's kind of unpredictable which I
really like and even though the combat
is more like you are directing a scene
rather than actively participating in it
because it's just cuties and it doesn't
really matter if you miss them it's
still very fun to watch so you can read
my full review for more thoughts on that
I'll leave a link below but basically my
idea is I feel like this is probably a
good foundation or a start of something
hopefully the future episodes won't
repeatedly tell me about that man's
parents being dead then of course we had
no man's sky I think they're a really
great components to no man's sky and
this sense of exploration in wandah that
I had in my first period of time playing
is very hard to parallel in another game
maybe minecraft is one thing that's very
similar just sure drop somewhere and
it's just like explore and I did and I
was very excited too and I was very
excited by everything that I found so
I'm not playing no man's guy anymore
I didn't play very much no man's sky but
I'm hoping to kind of be in
euro so Nevada malcontent that it can be
a game that I can get really hooked on
and I feel like it it has the potential
for that thankfully I was not one of the
people who was super excited about it so
I'm not disappointed in it and I'm not
angry about no man's sky not having a
lot of compelling content obviously
there's a lot of content you could play
it for hours but I don't think most of
it is compelling so I'm just hopeful
that it will improve of course
technically it is still marvelous and
impressive then we have Suicide Squad
which I didn't think was as bad as most
of my friends thought it was I thought
the start and the introduction to all
characters was very interesting and well
done but the villains are very boring
and the editing was very odd
I hated Batman vs Superman I think that
movie is absolutely terrible I don't
think that Suicide Squad is terrible but
I feel like it does kind of have this
thing what DC is trying to rush their
movies so Suicide Squad considering all
of the characters has a pretty big scale
but no investment because they didn't
build up that movie like they did with
the Marvel movies they didn't have those
several years and different films before
they started with the Avengers so it's
like they want to be at the Avengers
level but they don't want to put in the
work to get there so it's just really
hard to invest in any of the characters
I felt like I liked Deadshot the most Oh
Will Smith
I thought the Joker was really bad I
thought Halle was fine but it's just
that most of it is edited in just the
most snappy ways I mean articles have
surfaced about the post-production off
to it so what I'm speculating here maybe
actually has some merit but it's
basically like everything is just cut so
there's no actual conversation like a
lot of it is just a scene with a
character saying one line I'm gonna cut
to the next thing and they just keep
doing that it's like it seems like it's
less common in that movie for individual
characters to actually talk to each
other and it's mostly just one character
saying something and then it cut to
someone else and then it cut to someone
else and it's like they're not
conversing which is just very odd
editing but I do want to mention that I
absolutely love DC I prefer DC of a
model I have a Batman tattoo and I read
more DC Comics than Marvel Comics I just
don't like the movies DC I'm making at
the moment and I really wish that they
would make better ones inside came out
on ps4 I
talk about this on my last month's
highlights but seriously plan side it is
great that's all I'm gonna say just play
it and then I sell sausage potty which
is moved from seth rogen uh this one's
weird to talk about it's not a bad movie
because the pacing is good the narrative
makes sense but it was a comedy and i
didn't laugh once in that movie I feel
like there are a few moments mostly
relating to some creative puns where I
was like huh but I didn't actually laugh
out loud even once because it seemed
like the butt of most of the jokes was
food swearing like legitimately a lot of
the jokes in that movie what just this
character is swearing a lot that's funny
I understand other people finding it
funny but this is a movie that's not for
me it's not a bad movie just on a moon
for me I also reviewed a game called
valley which is made by the same people
who might slender the arrival it's an
adventure game it is there's lots of
like speedrunning platforming moments
which is like it's like a first-person
sonic and in the parts where you're
going really fast it's super cool but
then it kind of slows you down a lot of
the time to make you explore this wall
that it's very hard to get invested in
it's not very long the combat is really
boring it's definitely pretty but the
mechanics are kind of nonsensical and
forced and the story is just it has
interesting a law but it's just you have
no stakes or stakeholders because the
valley is empty except you so it just
felt like it was pointless I'll leave a
link to my review on that one also I
don't want to talk about it too much
because I feel like most people haven't
heard of it so probably don't care
Deus Ex came out I haven't had a chance
to play too much of that unfortunately
but from why I have played I really like
it it's very intuitive I love the south
options and it's also quite hard which I
mean I suck at stealth games anyway so I
say they're all hard but it's just the
way the environments in structured
provide a very unique kind of challenge
and anyone who enjoys stealth games will
really like Deus Ex though of course you
don't have to play it stealth believe
you don't want to you can just go in at
guns blazing so it gives you that
creativity and freedom as well which is
really cool and then last but not least
I sell Kubo which is a stop-motion film
that is just really lovely who I was
surprisingly laid out like a video game
I like there are levels and bosses which
I wonder if they drew inspiration from
video games because I kept thinking that
and that's actually always really cool
to see in a movie but there were parts
of it that didn't really make sense some
things that happened you know what
justified or explained very well but I
feel like I could ignore those things
based on one thinking that it was very
pretty and two it was just so pleasant
to watch also in like sound design and
voice acting was great and the
principles or I guess just the fairytale
aspects of it were just really lovely
it's also impossible not to appreciate
the craft in that kind of movie I saw a
facebook video that was like a
time-lapse of them building some of
these characters and one of the bosses
which is just huge it's way too open
people and that is just so impressive I
think it took them five years to make
the movie and it looks great and I
believe that was it the stuff that I
checked out in August alrighty I will
see you guys next time